we've been digging into the decipherment
of ancient scripts but what is a script
I'm convinced well it's a lot along our
journey into decipherment
if we don't pack an understanding of
writing systems to take along with us so
at this point I plan to spend a few
minutes racing over the basics of
writing with you but however hard I
tried to condense it and pack it in it's
scratched form or scratched the old
Greek root for writing graph meant
scratch like scratching symbols into
rock or clay graph themes are written
units like the letter V a semicolon the
Han character for fire the actual marks
that get written down our glyphs here
are some glyphs for the graphene V and
here are some glyphs for fire little
marks called diacritics can modify those
glyphs here's an O with the nasal mark
telling you to pronounce it through the
nose ooh here's that same diacritic
above the letter A diacritics
are often simplified or miniature
versions of other glyphs so that little
nasal mark comes from the letter n put
atop another character notice that a
single graphene can be written with
various glyphs these glyphs are all
allografts other scratches of the
graphene v these glyphs are all alle
graphs of fire very roughly a set of
graphemes that get used together in
writing make up a script a script
together with the way it encodes or
represents language is a writing system
graph e makes wonders about writing
system things like the use of certain
symbols for certain sounds or certain
meanings or the differences between
different writing systems then there's
graph X which wants to know about things
like the shape and composition of
letters or the mechanics of human hand
writing the word writing can mean any of
these
I really want to put some art and
thought into this separate voyage
through writing so that we can make the
most of decipherment tune in for both
and subscribe for language
you